[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host on sockin super excited to
be talking about nature-based
evolutionary spirituality we have Josh
silver joining us on the show hydrogen
yeah yeah thanks for coming on really
appreciate it it's a great pleasure to
be here so pumped so pumped for this
conversation right thank you thank you
for those who don't know Josh's
background he's been pursuing expanded
consciousness for over 40 years and you
can find his links in the bio below Wow
today's been so much fun we've been
literally having a ball yeah we've been
playing basketball we were playing with
throwing discs around hanging out with
Ori and his brother gal who's been a lot
of fun it's been a lot of fun we've been
like unleashing our inner child a lot
today yeah great and the way that you
engage with nature is so beautiful and
I'm so pumped to be talking about that
and kind of the new paradigms if we can
systematically awaken spiritually yeah
let's start things off by asking one of
our favorite questions what are your
thoughts on the direction of our world
well it's best of all worlds and the
worst of all worlds we have access to
all the world's knowledge and we have in
a lot of places the opportunity to
pursue that and just the there's an
evolution of consciousness that is
what's happening on the planet at the
same time we're mired in a media
generated world that is so
[Music]
it's well it's it's it's pretty horrible
it's it's a horrible way to represent
what existence is and when if you look
at what's coming out of the screens
mostly this is it's just bad for our
souls bad for its it's it's a there's so
much coming in and but and it's no one's
fault
we're also at a point in the evolution
of consciousness and of the planet where
we're dealing with things that we've
never had a deal with before these
bodies these organisms evolved mostly in
tribes of 150 people or less mm-hmm
that's so important to understand that
we're designed to be with people that we
know that we care about that we work
together if you didn't work together
you're ostracized race was the worst
thing if you are isolated not part of
the group we live in a world that's so
different than that and all the trends
are to isolate us isolate us to make us
fearful we live in a system where the
Jeep GDP is based on people buying
things and so we become these objects of
this system that tries to make us into
consuming units by separating us by
having a sphere by making us feel bad
about ourselves that makes us more
reliable to buy things so what's worse
for our well being is better for the GDP
so we're at odds with a system and so
and it's worse and worse and the speed
up the speed up I raised five children
my children at 2739 we raised them
without screens because we recognize
that that we did not want the culture
raising our kids we wanted to instill
these values well that's obviously more
or the case so I've been very sensitized
that issue and so the state of the world
is such that whereas the the trends are
making it harder and harder there's more
and more opportunity and that's why the
nature of evolution so that's a it's an
essential part and I like talking about
things that are essential there's
certain things that are essential and
the evolutionary nature of reality is
essential then there we now have working
knowledge of what existence is and what
existence is in this corner of the
universe so we live in this evolving
universe and what that means is that the
nature of things is that it's unlimited
and it's better and better and there's
increasing complexity and harmony and
way things come together I mean this
organism is gorgeous it's believed it's
unbelievable that from nothing from the
earth yes we evolve these capacities yes
and so what I've come to especially is
to go back to our roots that were so
profoundly cut off from nature including
human nature that were lost and it would
make sense that the world would be bad
mm-hmm because we're cut off from our
roots if if if we weren't if it wasn't
bad cutting off for our roots then what
would we need roots for our
disconnection from nature is immediately
mirrored in the problems in our
civilization yes and from our own nature
and from our own nature so and we'll
talk about my path because
let's get into that right now let's do
it so the journey right who were you
growing up and how did you even get
interested in this stuff right well I
grew up in a very wonderful bubble I
grew up in suburbia and v I was born in
1954 so I grew up I played a lot you're
65 I'm 64 years old you're crushing it
the way you were playing basketball
today was on fire you know you have
taken such good care of your health and
that's you know we'll talk about some of
the methods throughout the journey but
just like wow yeah we should you you act
as a role model for so many of us to be
able to play with that much enthusiasm
and compassion and then success yeah
yeah it's it's a gift it's a gift and
yeah we'll talk about that so how I
started out was I did play a lot of
sports and I was co-captain my high
school basketball team and soccer teams
yeah my father was a rabbi well-known
rabbi who did not believe in God so he
was a reformed rabbi so what that means
is that he was getting to the essence of
Judaism getting rid of the traditional
things that weren't relevant anymore all
the dietary things and and focusing on
what's important so my dad what was
important was the teaching and the
teaching was about loving each other so
he didn't know the term but he was a
karma yogi karma yogi is selfless
service so I was his oldest son so I
grew up very much I three younger
brothers so my path was to take care of
my brothers to take care of people and
so that's what I did and I lived a happy
life as far as I knew but very limited I
mean baseball was my God my gods were
statistics you know
make batting average bet all the
statistics I mean getting the base of
that baseball almanac was this thick
when I was like 12 years old that was
just like it was like my Bible it was
just like because back then you didn't
know anything I'll tell you a story this
really happened I was a fanatic about
sports and so I'm driving with my in the
car with my mom all of a sudden I go
stop the car she slams on the brakes I
jump out of the car I run back to a
house we just passed I burst through the
front door of this house
hi mrs. whittlin hi mrs. first I say to
them I go to the den I turn on the TV
it's like come on come on come on the TV
comes on and I saw Tommy Agee steal home
plate so turn off the TV bye mrs. Witten
but mrs. first this is my best friend
Bree it just passed his house so I get
back to the car my mom's like what the
hell what what happens you could have
killed us I mean did the way you
streamed and you jumped out of the car
it's like but mom I was listening to the
game on the radio and I heard tell me
did you steal home plate and I'd never
seen anyone steal home plate before so I
knew we just passed Joel's house so I
went back to Joel's house and went in
and so I necessary play that so that was
like just an example of like how crazy I
was about sports also the fact that I'd
never seen anyone steal home plate yeah
you didn't have accidents that kind of
thing so that was just their crazy story
about living in that world that was my
world it was a sports baseball and
you've been an athlete your whole life
I've been an athlete my whole lives
yeah and playing and so when I got to
college I really was interested I had an
old I had a I had a half-brother who was
10 years older than me so he was out of
the house by the time I was 7 but he was
into he was a therapist and learning
about therapy so when I was barely 18
years old I was doing full-day workshops
like personal development workshops at
18 and so throughout college I'm in my
junior year I did 200 hours of personal
growth stuff at the primal scream I did
Gestalt therapy we did
an empathy training relationship I was
in a relationship thing with my
girlfriend for ten weeks where we did a
relationship learning about
relationships and interacting but I
realized that that there was something
more and I didn't know what that was
back end this is 1976 I graduated and it
was like there's something more than
psychology and I didn't know anything
about Eastern spirituality but I started
finding out and right after college had
an opportunity to meet someone named
Swami Muktananda and I met him and
everything changed so I have been
geeking out a half hour meditation when
I met him I went to his program as
intensive and there were two sessions
that he says in Sunday where he went
around and he imparted his touch and he
said he was a city from the city
tradition he would awaken your Kundalini
and guide it well all I knew was that I
went to the meditation for two and a
half three hours my mind just turned off
I'm like what the [ __ ] like I just and
and as I mentioned my father who is
reformed rabbi getting rid of traditions
and so what I didn't say was Friday
night I went there and I saw I didn't
know what I'd to expect but I saw people
bowing down to someone which was in
Judaism that's an athame you don't bow
down to a person it's all about the
teachings that's what Christians do they
wish it we don't do that so that's what
I I knew that was true and I also knew
that all this traditional stuff all
these all the rituals that was not
legitimate either in my mind those were
not legitimate avenues of personal
growth or spiritual or anything so even
though my mind was saying well I don't
know what's going on here and it's not
really valuable but I'm here for the
weekend so in that space I had these
amazing meditations so it totally blew
my mind so I had it just I just received
my bar mitzvah money when I graduated
college so I had just enough money to
spend two more months there with
Muktananda
and then I was hooked I
I spent the next four years in and out
of ashrams I was celibate than the drugs
just totally on this path of meditating
three and a half hours a day
chanting three and a half hours a day
and just opening to spirit what I did
that was unusual is because because it
so blew my mind I said I give up my all
my concepts like I also Manomet after
college so it was I was completely open
in my life I didn't have anything
anything agenda so I spent the next four
years basically letting go of all my
concepts except one the only thing I
knew was true and this was literally
like I really don't know what's true the
only I know is true is that everything
is energy both Western science and
Eastern spirituality agree that
everything is energy
now these Eastern mystics they talk
about the nature that being bliss and
what I came to realize is that well
Western science doesn't say that but
they just haven't invented an instrument
to measure the bliss that is actually
what we are we are the Bliss meters we
are that that is the nature of existence
it is and using bliss is just I mean
using words which is a big problem we're
in right now we're so in this world word
world and word world cannot begin it can
begin to touch that which is beyond the
word the the concrete world so when you
talk about bliss of existence it's so
beyond just like so we work to become
like a tuning fork with nature which is
always resonating as a tuning fork and
then you can see the humans that are
attuned to nature on that same
vibrational frequency and then on the
other the energetic frequency and then
on the other side we have we can tell
there's just
not tuned whatsoever to nature humans as
well and so that's this juxtaposed
dichotomy between those two and some now
we're talking about you know your
journey to tune yourself more towards
nature and how other people can also
tune themselves more towards nature yeah
well it's a good tuning tuning fork is a
good analogy and that's the vibration I
mean that is the meditative state is is
nature's just doing it existence is just
doing it we've overlaid the humans have
overlaid it with all these concepts with
all these ways of separating them it's
also really hard when you're in the
middle of a metropolis to think that
like nature is tuning right now because
when you are out in the middle of the
woods or by the ocean or wherever you
are in actually immersed in nature you
can totally feel it there in the
metropolis it's really even though you
can around EMF and buses in cars and a
hundred thousand oh yes you can tune in
but it's like way hard is this way hard
yes it is and that's that's one reason
why it's it's that's the worst of the
things because we are so disconnected
and I think there's that's our I think
over 50% of people now live in
Metropolis and and they've done studies
where they show where there's less trees
and cities yeah there's worse health
outcomes like it just it's just a fact
so now we're getting back to the nature
part Japan has been studying the
benefits of nature for over 30 years and
their national government recognizes
that this is a positive thing and so
they've done things about blood pressure
and stress and all these things that
that nature immersion is a is a positive
thing cause each or therapy well yeah
there's or eco therapy you go there
haricots therapist and
so and more and more I mean this book
earthing book and and they're just
showing the benefits of this so I'm sure
is what was happening for you I had the
ashrams like what you said
three-and-a-half hours a day meditations
mantras
well yo what we've looked in unto
whenever anyone who might ask him about
meditation you know how can I meditate
better he would always say chant more so
hmm so his so I come from an unusual
tradition which is that so he was a City
yogi
so his path was to worship his guru and
and by worshiping that those qualities
you become that that's that's the
philosophy behind it now obviously
they're they're issues with that and and
and Muktananda was someone who also got
in trouble in terms of scandal with with
with women and and that troubled me i
distance myself from that but it helped
to understand that we put people on
pedestals but they're human beings and
even though this and so someone like
Muktananda who was a monk his whole life
and never been around women and really
you know be in proximity but open to
that that the both the the orgasmic
nature of existence we experienced that
in our bodies with our orgasm I mean
that's that's I mean that's where
creation comes from we create babies
through orgasm yes okay that's our roots
so to have a spirituality that denies
that is not it it's limited there's a
limitation to that it's I can only see a
limitation to that and so and that's
when people talking about Tantra the
roots of Tantra are seeing everything as
being infused with this what I would
call evolutionary lifeforce no back then
they didn't know about evolution
but there my experience is this
evolutionary life force this is an
actual force that exists that we can tap
into and nature is the holder of that
that by being and that we can open
ourselves up to simply what is and it's
the it's the tuning fork it's it's the
North Star and it's what our bodies
crave think about it
this organism evolved those whose
organisms enjoyed life that who were
tapped into that which is that a
blissful nature of existence they're
gonna they're gonna survive they're
gonna pass on their genes more likely I
mean everyone knows that feeling good
being happy positive psychology is
that's good for your well-being
yeah okay so this is what our roots are
and and that's gonna convey an evolution
evolutionary advantage to us so it makes
sense it totally makes sense to get back
into touch with nature and to let that
inform us and our bodies are designed to
be in nature and to be in a co-creative
relationship with that one thing I love
doing is being out in the cold okay so
I'm not at the wim hof level though I
have I guess I've been in 34 degree
water what I've done hot cold but it's
more nature based wim HOF it's like if
I'm outside and I often love to be
outside at sunrise and sunset and it can
be cold and my body wants to experience
nature as much as possible so the least
amount of clothes on is better so it's
it's that energy of the cold is very
stimulating you really have to open to
it and
take it in and and and it best be one
with it yes but really open to that
that's something that conveys I mean I
love hearing when wim HOF talk about how
it's so good for our health that that
the cold squeezes our capillaries and
gives us energy and gives us vitality
and helps our immune system fight things
off so nature just being in it as it is
that's just one your the coldest is a
beautiful way to open to this natural
way of being and and to allow my body to
want that so I want to be in the cold
because I want to experience the
experienc nature as directly as I
possibly can
yes so this is one of the keys to
experience in nature as directly as
possible this has been a key to your
nature based spiritual awakening and
this is one that you also hope to make
into a systemic spiritual evolutionary
process for all of us right what are
some of the continued going down this
pot what are some of those systemic
process well what's interesting is that
so three years ago in the 40th
anniversary of getting shafted pot is
called from Muktananda I knew that I
would experience a rebirth of some kind
and what it was was was to be literally
experienced myself as a child of the
Father Son Mother Earth so I just look
at the Sun and it reminds me of the
father who sends his energy out in this
stream to the feminine the feminine
receives it and creates all of this yes
you know or as my father said from the
pulpit he said God created man he looked
at man and said I can do better than
that and created Eve so the fact the
feminine takes the masculine energy and
then creates this amazing I mean
millions of species it's so it's it's
it's so I mean I'm just uh I just go
into all
and what existence actually is and so I
try to experience that as purely
directly and also as a child would in
that pure like oh my god I mean I just
see a bug it's like how do you do that
you know like this little I mean it
whatever it is it's so remarkable so I
can I can go off on reading about nature
I love the movie seeing the Sun as the
father and the mother earth receiving
the energy and then being able to birth
a hundred million species over time Plus
and yeah now we have about ten or so
million it's what we've calculated and
and that's still out of all of the
species there's one that is just
unbelievably as a variable just weighted
so much greater than all the other ones
we are now stewards we are now becoming
gods and we must increase our wisdom so
that we can hold yield that power and be
able to preserve the light of
consciousness spread the light of spread
creativity spread all these things
further but I love how you can just look
at all of the species and the oceans all
the species on land and just like you
can find you can fall in love with being
in this sunny and fall in love with
laying in the grass this is this you can
in it you can feel like it's that is
with unity that's oneness it's purity
love yeah well it's it's a remarkable
experience and and my shorthand way of
talking about it is the Sun human earth
so this is so this form she Bob's
evolved from the Sun and the earth and
so Sun human earth is sh-sh-she so I I
just
open to the the gift the gift of being
that that I am she I that so and this is
really important in terms of this whole
notion this whole spiritual notion of
getting rid of your ego by getting rid
of the I so so when I was with booked
Ananda so this is back in the 70s so I
did four years and there was a lot of
that talk about getting rid of the eye
and just not you know being one with
everything getting rid the eye to drop
rejoining the ocean yeah right and so
that's a wonderful that's a I I think of
that as a foundation so once you do that
then how do you interact in this world
how do you bring the essence this unique
essence that we are which is as
important this is this is what we have
to be here so as a child literally up
sheet above the Sun and the earth that
evolve this form I am both humbled
because compared to that I am I think of
myself as an aunt like I am an aunt
going about my in this magnificence yes
and at the same time because I am of
that magnificence
I am magnificence myself so I it's like
The Lion King so it's it's recognizing
that and and that's why actually
experiencing it because we live in a
world where experience what human beings
experience is dwindling right we don't
even we don't we rarely talked to people
on the phone now we write things and
then we don't even feel them we let our
emojis indicate emotions for us so I
just see these this is a trend where
we're getting less and less human less
and less emotionally
present and and and experiencing that
whereas on the good side and the good
side of life now there's so many models
there's there's so much freedom to be
when we lived in small tribes you were
pretty much in what the tribe was and
these tribes were self-sufficient they
were in they were in the ecosystem and
they pretty much stayed the same we live
in this now it's unprecedented we can
beat anything and we have these models I
mean the machines that are so amazing
that the humans have created they give
us models we give us models I mean it
used to be that you would have to write
on parchment right in order to change
something that's written in parchment
that's a big deal now we just change
things like that so this idea of change
is so much more possible now because we
have these models that make sense to us
that show us how to do it and we can
take on these attributes in ways we
couldn't before so I want you to speak
to us about the things within the like
let's say that maybe the last you know
couple of decades as you've been
refining your nature based spiritual
practice and and as you've been seeing
the exponential technology each kick off
and more and more of the devices are
widespread
what are maybe some of those key she the
son human earth practices that we can
buddy
so one of my shorthand ways of thinking
about it is that you can add XI to
anything okay
and so so when I'm outside so I'll be
doing yoga
okay so I'll do yoga practices and I
mean one of the most famous ones is
obviously salutations of the Sun so I
mean that was designed to be done at
with the Sun which we kind of did from
in their intro video a basketball right
we're just so we're so so when I'm
standing there I am a conduit between
the Sun and the earth and so I and I
think of myself as this the Sun and the
earth evolve me so that I could be that
conduit so I could expand my
consciousness and and and lend that self
to this interplay of Sun and Earth and
and then there's another evolution of
that because well I guess I'll go into
it now and you can complete that's
exactly yes yeah
so that truly is who we are
so as I said it's book humbling and then
also like glorious to be that and it's
it's a way to keep on track so when I
was with Muktananda for four years I
meditated all that time but the
experience really was a lot from the
neck up so I'm in that oneness like
everything is one I knew everything was
one in nature that is bliss that was my
meditation so that was cool
I mean that was really great it's
interesting to go back to the same
ashram I was in then and meditate and I
and there's so much more embodiment now
so now it's my whole body
MMI is is expanding the point I was
gonna make yeah so it keeps me on track
so when we open to the universal it's
really easy to get off track it's really
easy to sort of lose your bearings it's
like okay well I know it's one but like
so how I how I conceptualize it is by
staying on track with the Sun and the
earth it's almost literally like I am in
that vibration and I am in that
alignment I've really waited for fairly
recently to go to the universal because
I wanted to make sure I had this I had
this in place and really rooted because
I've been very concerned about tapping
into this energy but if I'm not really
on track then I can get into trouble so
along with all this spiritual stuff I
have a master's in counseling psychology
I've been living with a therapist for
the last six years who has been
phenomenal to keep me on track and
dealing with my own personal issues and
going through my my personal psychology
because these this unconscious that we
have and we all of us have unconscious
various about judges I mean young talked
about the shadow
people know about this but these things
they run us I mean Bruce Lipton who
developed the concept of epigenetics he
among others talked about 95% of us are
unconscious we're operating
unconsciously so I've been very very
careful to align myself up before I
start by cheering this because frankly
I've been scared shitless that I'm gonna
like to screw up and I haven't won it
because I want to be in my full power
but I see how I'm run by things how yeah
you know my issues with my mother so
like one thing that happened was I had
an experience on mother's day where I
just felt that I was bonded with the
earth and I just felt her and I was out
with her and and I am from that and
there was a depth of experiencing that
that instantly I could feel my dynamic
with my mother and with women change
that I had this route like people talk
about a six-year bond like the but you
need a secure bond and they talk about
the mother well you can't get a secure
bond with a human anymore
I mean maybe at some point you could
when we were indigenous and we were one
with nature and the the woman was
embodiment but nowadays were to say it
we're so screwed up we have so we have
so many areas that aren't clear in us
that we can't help picking that up from
our parents and from the culture and so
it's no one's fault but we're not we we
can't have a secure bond with life and
so that's what felt like happened is
that I felt this secure bond with
existence and then I didn't need my
mother I didn't need a woman or others
to love me in a certain way it was just
it just relaxed and what I found is as I
immerse myself in nature and ice
three or four hours a day outside
barefoot opening hmm that that has
supplanted my my trying to get that in a
human realm and hmm interesting so you
passing these three to four hours a day
in a deeper communion with the spirit of
nature of the earth that gave birth to
us and with the Sun the she process you
communing with that for multiple hours a
day through a myriad of practices is one
of the ways that you feel like has just
accelerated your spiritual evolution and
you think that others going deeper into
this nature based style is one of the
biggest keys it's essential it's not
like you can't you can't meditate more
you can't chant more you can't affirm
more you can't be in a we space more you
need nature that is that is what we come
from a and it's it gives us so much
energy gives us someone else being but
it keeps us aligned I mean so you know
practices so I do yoga I'm doing yoga
outside you know I'm leaning in the
trees I'm with the earth so that I'm
opening to those spaces and you know
when I mean that's a beautiful thing
about yoga you're stretching into those
spaces when I stretch into them when my
hands are feeling the earth I'm taking
in the energy of the earth as I open
into this wonderful space so nature just
makes it better it's just and I mean
think about it people were doing yoga
before they were doing it outside didn't
have yoga mats it's unusually up and
touching the earth than doing it but
it's it just simply better so I'll do
that I have sound this is really
important so actually let me say a
little bit more about my
the training with with Muktananda so his
training his path was to awaken
Kundalini to transmit that through his
touch and then and that sounds very far
out for those that mean okay we're that
so so I'll tell you in a easier way I
mean one way to think about is mirror
neurons one way to think about is
someone yawning or laughing when someone
does that we're just were able to do
that so this is just somebody who spent
40 years meditating hours a day in this
state of consciousness so it's it's
simply conveying that there's nothing
there's nothing fancy about it there's
nothing esoteric about it it's just a
simple transmission he had a gift and he
was able to to transmit that they bring
that as wherever they go with them after
you've practiced for decades of that and
you can direct it and you can and you
can you can be more I mean especially
when you get good at it then you can
really direct it kind of thing but every
but I mean you know there's so many
people who are doing hands-on healing I
mean it's just it's just the nature of
existence to transmit what we can to
others and then also this capacity
everything is interconnected right
everything is everything is this
energetic soup so if you're I mean
that's what I do in nature is just open
as much as I can but that's what I did
with my so my spiritual teacher was that
was his path was which was to get that
now so I started doing this nature based
thing and then a year into that I heard
from someone who knew my is Swami
Muktananda he said do you know who dr.
TRAI is so dr. TRAI is in he's a hint
back in eastern spirituality Hinduism or
even before that he was a guru who is in
the same tradition the city tradition
but he was the prime Oriole guru he
didn't have a teacher a human teacher he
worshipped nature so he worshiped the
Sun the earth the elements and animals
yes so I didn't know that but that was
in my tradition so that was such a
wonderful
confirmation for me that I was on the
rack right track and so I just started
doing things like there's an usher I'm
in Oakland and I would sit there and
there are three sessions and I would go
in the hall and open to this the energy
there and then I would go outside and
practice outside and the same thing I
would do the same thing which is to open
non conceptually so what I do is I do my
best to open non conceptually to allow
myself to be informed by this
magnificence that's beyond you know that
which created this I have no idea how
that could happen
how 60 trillion cells could be operating
but that's what's going on here
and I open to the genius and the
magnificence that created all that and
do my best to get out of any thought I
have about it or any concept and simply
open to it so I do different I mean I
have different mantras mantras or every
moment new is a mantra I do you know
every moment every moment new yeah which
is true so the biggest practice is my
breath so my dad was a reformed rabbi to
get to the simple the essence of what
Judaism was in this case I'm trying to
get to the essence of what spirituality
is so it starts with breath so breath is
its it's the polarity so dancing with
polarities is huge okay so in and out so
we were given that we're given the way
to get familiar with the outgoing breath
in the incoming breath just like you
know so the teacher that's always with
us it's always with us and and and so
you know I used to do whenever I would
get off track it's like oh yeah I'm
gonna do fly breaths I'm just gonna do
five breaths and I conceptionally I'm
here and what I found was you know the
train myself so by the fifth breath I
was back in it I was back in that state
in that alignment with with with what is
yeah as much as I could so you know and
I'm living more consciously after that
versus living more unconsciously prior
to
deeper connection via the breath yes
nature so and and and actually inhaling
through my nose that happened a year and
a half ago and that really changed
things for me that there's something
called GU tako breathing that helps with
asthma but this idea breathing in
through your nose that what I found is
so breathing it through your mouth for
me it creates more anxiety so it's like
like I'm I can gasp for breath where I
can hold my breath so it when I just
breathe in through my nose
then I'm taking in and especially when
I'm in nature I'm taking in and I'm just
taking in goodness so there's no there's
nothing in the way of simply allowing
that to come in and it for me and so
that's what I do and sometimes you know
I can do
the latest thing I've done is I have a
double three-part breath so I'll breathe
in through my nose
I'm usually standing when I do this well
let's do it we have we have a shot where
we can stand while we do this let's do
the exercise together so we have frame
Maureen yes okay good
so the in breath so I breathe in through
my nose belly chest and head so okay
okay and then so then I'll breathe in is
all I can and then I'll breathe in
through my mouth belly chest and head
okay okay cool feel the difference so
it's so this actually so so where we
starting nose so say we start we always
start with nose so no stare windows okay
breathe into your belly jazz
breathing shallowly
and you can retain your breath or just
just let it flow so that that's a really
deepening so it's it's it's getting the
nose
so it's guru ding with the nose into
yourself and then my breathing in
through your mouth then you can even
then you can really expand even more so
and I just find so so there's that
freedom of opening and so with
Muktananda he kriyas would happen around
him so the idea was to when you're in
meditation and and back in the day in
the back of the hall people would be
doing like making sounds and moving and
just it's just a spontaneous whatever
your it's trusting the body whatever
wants to happen so when I'm in nature so
it's so like this movement it's as if
there's everything as movement
everything is moving and so it's as I'm
loosening and opening and allowing then
I just find my body just naturally I
mean this shaking is something that
people want to recommend is this destiny
openness the idea that so I mean we want
to have our our consciousness open and
expand it well if your body is open and
expanded then it's it's just gonna
follow that your consciousness is gonna
follow that so I think about the full
spectrum so I think about the the
physical emotional mental and
consciousness like how to have all of
them open and free so how to feel
anything so whatever I feel good and bad
I simply go back to my because it you
know sometimes I'll feel just oh my god
this is so amazing I'm one with the
ecosystem this is so phenomenal in it
right but then it's like just go to my
breath don't get wrapped up in it right
don't get wrapped up in this what I
would call the small I
a small eye and the small eye one way
you know you're in your small is when
you're thinking about evaluation self
evaluation or thinking about what others
might think right that's small I
thinking
so this big eye versus big yeah so as I
was saying before as she on both day
aunt but I'm connected to everything so
so so I am we can sit you up so I'm in a
sense I'm both simultaneously I am it's
not it's so I was saying before it's not
like your ego goes away it's not your
essence goes away I am that and I'm
fully that but I'm at the same time I'm
connected to the magnificence and I'm
one so mmm I don't get wrapped up in it
I experience it and of course we have
these needs we have these desires to
connect and to be valued and all the
interpersonal stuff that's going on and
it's a matter of acknowledging that and
then opening to our bigger self as well
so another really powerful aspect of
nature-based spiritual evolution is that
nature is the best teacher so when we're
in in immersed in nature
when you actually go and lay down in the
grass you actually get to see the grass
and you get to see the nuance of the
dirt and the insects and all those
things then when you get closer to a
tree when you're actually there hugging
the tree smelling the tree touching the
tree more finally actually just being
there with it and feeling its roots and
its leaves and how it houses so many
other creatures that live within it so
there's like a just a more again it's
becoming the best teacher you get to see
the flight of a butterfly you get to you
get
see the squirrel jumped from a branch to
another branch and these are the things
the way that the ants actually moved
together so it just it becomes the best
teacher in a sense you actually and then
of course of all these like decreasing
cortisol decreasing inflammation
increasing spiritual connection unity
most types of things you learn so much
from being a student of nature and you
like to take it up a notch - well right
so this forest bathing I'm I'm going for
the forest immersion and just the you
know the fire hose yeah so so often I'll
use plant medicine to do that okay so
when I was with Muktananda and when I
raised my kids that most of the time for
25 years I didn't drink or smoke
marijuana at all because I wanted to
demonstrate that you don't need these
things in order to to enjoy life when
you engage in life and then but
marijuana especially for me was a real
opening when I was in college and really
opened me to a whole nother realm and so
I'm using that in a sacred way yes
so I used marijuana went on outside and
I also use it when I did so freeform
dance is another thing that's so I was
doing freeform dance and I still doing
it but three out three times a week for
it's been four years are we talking you
know a couple I'm talking about ecstatic
grams instead it was the dosing of
cannabis Oh cannabis a cool milligrams
so I I that what I do is I take a hit
off of I take and I'd like doing it
naturally I like blazing flower
yeah I mean I like using my wooden match
yes yes and I and I and I do it and I go
oh mama they shiva-shakti oh mama they
shiva-shakti so in the tradition of
India the Assad is going back they would
worship Shiva and they would smoke
cannabis I mean this is part of the
spiritual tradition in that part of the
world and of course obviously there's
many traditions that use sacred plant
medicine because it's tuning me into
nature
it's simply I mean what with marijuana
does it it opens the gating mechanisms
to experience more so wherever I am it
opens me more so I don't need it so I
mean you saw me today I wasn't I wasn't
on anything I just I just I'm out there
and it just yes it's just vibrating me
and I think it's really important to use
these these plant medicines are here
it's it's the earth is giving us these
gifts secreting them to use in the best
way possible to reconnect so in a sacred
way in a sacred way and then to me one
way people say well what's sacred that
sounds so like I don't to me anything
that's connected to nature is sacred
even like sacrificing the Sagi sacred
comes from sacrifice sacrificing your
sense of yourself in this mediated world
like that existence is small either the
joshua stewart silver there's silver
that i am that's i need to sacrifice
that smaller sense of myself to open to
something more something bigger so
that's so that's nature so that's what i
do so i take a hit and generally are
wait a half hour or all what I do is
because it troubles me so much the way I
see so much
being used I see it being used like
alcohol to numb people and and and even
the practice of it's often the case well
I you take a hit and it's like oh I'm
coming down I'm gonna take another hit
too like so I challenged myself so I
generally challenged myself to open more
than I ever had so when I take a hit I
tell myself you have never been this
high before this is this is this is the
highest you've ever been because this
evolutionary path every day is the next
step so when I take a hit it's like okay
I'm gonna open and experiencing more
expansion than I ever have and then when
I do I reward myself with another hit so
generally I take a couple of hits over
the course of three hours occasionally I
might take another one up longer but
that's generally what my what my
practice has been and I've done that
pretty much every day for it's going on
29 months
hmm so it's like 800 and
in 60 days or something some number in
there of simply opening and I think of
it as expanded consciousness food that
when I'm in nature and I'm receiving I
am simply opening and allowing myself to
be transformed and we can talk more
about that like what what it's possible
with that but what I'll say about it
because it's it's it's an extreme thing
that I'm doing and one reason I'm doing
it is because I look around me because I
go back to my roots my when I was with
Muktananda all I could think about is
how can i how can I be of service how
can I be of service please let me be of
service please let me be of service
and when I look at the world and it's so
troubled right now that well join and
macey talk about three different things
that are important it's important to
stop the stop the horrific things that
are happening it's important to take
care of those who have been harmed by it
as the third thing is it's important to
create new models yeah okay so I mean I
had a nonprofit where I was the
Fatherhood initiative I was helping
father's low-income dads you know back
in the day and talk parenting classes
and that kind of thing now what it seems
like this organism is designed for is to
explore this new paradigm this new
possibility of what the emerging
metahuman can be and so I've been on
this quest to open myself that I just as
I I often think about for almost a
billion years there was only one celled
creatures on the planet and then they
were clogging the oceans and and wife
was not didn't look like it was going to
survive and then somehow he's one celled
creatures figured out how to get energy
from the Sun
photosynthesis once that happened this
huge proliferation of life on the planet
yeah well when I'm out there I'm
thinking well if one cell creatures can
figure out how to get energy from the
Sun I got lotsa and and we have self you
know we're very much similar the cells
we have that are like plants we still
have them in our body they're like I've
heard 60% similar as you know a tree the
cells we have that are tree like from
when we evolved through that process so
I'm thinking they're in a I might be
crazy but I'm also like thinking well
the world is really in trouble I'm going
to open and see if I can bring in
something new some energy some
consciousness something I'm good there's
a further evolution I mean evolution
happened I think people think well that
was in the back in the day there was
evolution now there's no evolution we've
already achieved what it is we're
supposed to achieve well that doesn't
make any sense
or where we are but I mean we can still
evolve I mean that's that's so I'm open
so I mean there's some things that I've
noticed I've noticed that my energy is I
mean I'm 64 years old I have no regular
yoga practice I have no regular physical
activity that I just do I don't eat a
special diet I used to you know I
studied nutrition in college I know
about nutrition I eat a good balance but
I don't take no supplements and yet I
just was a you know I was just at the
outside lands the festival in San
Francisco you know for 13 hours a day
you know 13 hours I'm just playing I
just have energy and it feels like it's
it's simply allowing nature you send the
earth to play through this this physical
form and whatever energy I have it just
comes through when when it's called when
so if someone's dancing I'm going to
dance with them when someone's playing
in a play with them and I open and allow
nature to play through me enough for
that to happen so it's pretty remarkable
I've had healing things to the so we can
use plant medicines in a sacred and
responsible way to assist us with this
nature based spiritual evolution also I
think I think it's really important I
think it's because we live in such a
dense or a world that that's so cut off
of nature that a lot of these
traditional ways are not sufficient to
the world we live in so you know 2,000
years ago if you were meditating you
lived in a world that was pretty much
nature based right we weren't that far
removed and so meditation could help us
get back in touch with that nowadays I
don't see that at all I don't see people
having like meditating and being able to
overcome the fact that 24/7 were being
bombarded with just horrible things and
just but even not even horrible but the
fact that as I said beginning we used to
be in tries 150 people to like having to
be know all these tragedies are
happening all over the world we simply
are not designed emotionally to handle
that a machine can handle it a left
brain can like oh yes another massacre
but as an emotional being we simply are
not designed for that and you know when
I raised my kids without TV back in the
this is back in the 90s when they said
8000 you'd see a by the time you got to
be 18 you see 8,000 murderers your
deaths or something like that inherently
desensitizes a human being you can't you
just have to be desensitized so I look
around the
world today to go back to your initial
question and I see a world where people
are extremely desensitized and you don't
know it because that's just the world
we're in but compared to just looking a
baby look at a child that's open and but
but even then it's hard to see even
children who are being born are being
born into this world Tomas Hugo I just
heard him really beautifully talk about
just that we're born into trauma we just
born into this and and and how
challenging that is to eat but but to
acknowledge that that in this amazing
world were just traumatized and we're
operating in it and everyone has PTSD
it's just subclinical but it just it's
just who we are as a species at this
point and we aim to sensitize ourselves
more by going through this nature braced
practice and that's what's so hard about
it because it's it is a real leap it is
a real leap to open and it's essential
it's essential and then it helps you be
with other so being with nature helps
you be with human nature and another
human being because then you it's like
oh I can open to this magnificence that
you are even though there might be
behaviors or outer things or
I might be pretty you know but to keep
going to that place of connecting and
seeing this magnificence that's in each
of us each every human being yes yes
deep eye contact periods really help a
lot with that yeah yeah
and that sensitizing ourselves more to
magnificence and being very aware of
that Dunbar number like you're
describing 150 and while how we get
desensitized by the things that are
happening and the eight billion sphere
and then that amount of people let's um
let's talk about play let's talk about
how you play um will you grab the disc
for us we will get the disc and we share
that on the program would you be okay
with that okay cool yeah go go grab it
for us I want to I don't really want to
share that with everybody we played we
played with this with this knitted disc
for I don't know maybe almost an hour at
the earlier part of the day is the
pretty one I love that the pretty on
it's so gorgeous so these are pocket
discs yeah and these are really neat
because you can fold them up just like
this and just bring them with you so
easily anywhere and this one's obviously
gorgeously knit this is handmade in
Guatemala Fairtrade 100% cotton and it's
also if you guys are interested its
pocket disc calm and all you can contact
me and I can demonstrate it and because
it's yes let's do it so so the thing
about this play is so important because
it helps us get in touch with our child
aspects and you can do all sorts of
things with this yeah so so using both
hands so like so play is is it's an
antidote to both machine and left-brain
so I see that we I mean I love my mind
so the mind that can contemplate these
things that create create all these
things and when it is running things
and overwhelmed then we we forget about
play so I do I do see a dichotomy
between machines and and even life and
and play so plays one like machines when
you think about it having play in
something and you have a machine like
you don't want to have play in it right
it has to be exactly so well this is not
exactly Sony and this thing it's not
like you don't even throw it the same
way you can and add soft you can play
and you hit you I've got played with
kids all the time so but be able to play
with both hands deduce to have
creativity to never do the same thing
twice
that it was those are great yeah because
that that works on the ambidextrious
side of things both hands feet you play
it fee your mobile you're moving you're
never doing the same thing twice
that's very interesting yeah and and so
play is a primordial need you know the
original Stuart brown studied this was
when they first having mass killings and
he was sick this was like like what what
the hell's going on we we didn't
understand that you know that's more
common now and he studied and he found
that the the one thing that was common
among mass killers was a profound lack
of play in childhood Wow
so play just play as natural it gets us
in touch with what's natural and what
and being spontaneous and being in the
moment yeah so so that's why it's so
good and as I say it's an antidote to
having be having to be rigid and being
flexible yeah and
and so is it we expand our consciousness
this is a physical way to expand your
consciousness and yeah and it doesn't
matter like and we're so focused on
outer right says I say I was co-captain
a high school basketball team a soccer
team so I know about competition I know
about achieving I know about you know
doing things well but so but so much of
sport is not play it's it's like work
and self-esteem so to be able to do
something where you're not focused on
how you're doing so with this thing what
I like doing is it's not a matter of
whether you necessarily catch it or not
but when we're just throwing it's like
how quickly can you retrieve it and
throw it in the general direction of
someone so it's it's you're not
evaluating yourself and and you and you
keep it moving so you don't you don't
get lost in like oh whoa I missed that
or it's like before you can think that
it's coming back again and it's and
there are different games that I've
developed for this as well but this is
and it's natural and it's beautiful and
so this is this is a my way to introduce
the whole concept of of nature and of up
joy yeah of joy so another one of my
mantras is like is it inquiry how to
enjoy this moment how to enjoy this
moment and and that simply asking that
question is an expansive playful
response I mean generally it's its
opening more it's feeling good but but
that like the mind is good when you give
it a good question like that how to
enjoy this moment and your mind and your
body can figure out how to do that yeah
so that's yeah that's one of my go-to
--hz there's people that say oh I'm not
coordinated or whatever the excuse
limiting belief is and then
moments there just being able to throw a
toss and catch it'll play little
children gets so excited because you're
playing and they want to play and they
bond
it's a harmonious bond and and so yeah
I've seen magic with these and I mean
it's I mean one thing see we're having
generations now of kids who have parents
who didn't know how to play we haven't
played much so I just see it and but
what's so beautiful is that it can come
back so I mean I've been with kids who
have been on the autistic spectrum and I
throw it at them and they like have no
respect like they it's like they never
caught anything before or that I mean
it's just like it and I mean I've seen
kids go from that response to in five
minutes just jumping and and screeching
and playing you know eight nine year old
kids and then and then the little ones
the little ones I mean the two-year-olds
who just they're just enjoy like this
one is one locale two years old he was
playing with her and she would just like
go up the people like she just wanted to
would just go up to them and just throw
it to other people just like play with
me play with me just like play is
inherent it's it's it were animals and
and we forget that at our peril so this
is a way of getting in touch with with
both the the childlike part of us and
also the the animal part of us which is
also that's essential that's where
energy is that's where our creativity is
that's where learning is best when we're
are were a child and when if we tap back
into that we have it gives us access to
that that vitality and also that
expanding consciousness yes yes as our
star shines then it can help other stars
shine
I love that that's incredible way to put
it I have some questions that I want to
ask you about just life in general what
has been your relation with seeing
source as a unique creative expression
like creation like we're all paint
strokes or notes that are being played
in the symphony or the big art canvas of
creation is that how do you feel about
that it's not about how you feel about
it or how do you see it
we are unique expressions of this
magnificence and I think the universe
has created such miraculous abundant
expressions and we are one of that so I
trust that and so and then we get to
connect right so we just play basketball
today so I mean when we're playing
together I mean it's just so beautiful
when we were passing you know when we're
when we're working in sync and so this
idea that you know I can have an
experience but if I can connect with
another brilliant expression of it and
then we can find ways to have this
positive feedback loop where we're just
building on this joy so being so I love
doing freeform dance
and so the ecstatic dance I do something
called five rhythms or open floor but
basically it's expressing yourself with
other people and so we are this so
that's such to me it's also essential I
mean I don't see how you can get to the
place of being free without listening to
music I mean it's just the best way to
just let it just listen to the music and
then it's a meditation
it's a moving interactive meditation and
so and it's it's very good at letting go
of my own my own psychological issues so
if I see someone and I want to impress
them or I want to look good or all these
things that that are in us they want it
you know that in the in dance if I'm
doing that then I'm not I'm not in the
flow all right so it's it's going back
so a dance
one thing I'll do is like during that I
will take time you know I'll drink water
but several times during dance I will I
will pull myself back from that I will
sit down it'll get centered I open to
she and then I'll allow she to come
through me and then I will do something
which I call tuning in to the joy
channel so when I'm dancing with others
I'm open and I'm open to that place of
joy and playfulness in them and
connection and so when that happens then
there's a synergy that happens and then
it can really grow then we're really
talking so in terms of of connecting and
nature connecting to ourselves and then
sharing that there's a synergy that we
can tap into that is really
extraordinary
yes does it feel like we are on the Dow
or the path or does it feel like we are
off of the Dower the path where my sense
is is that the trends are did knock us
further off so I've been dancing for
several years now and I see more
separateness I see it harder for people
to connect I see that that it's a risk
just like it's a risk to do that and
people for the most part and this is a
generalization but the trend is to be
more self conscious to be more afraid of
like putting yourself out there and
getting
criticized or being there's something
wrong with me that that it's there's a
risk in and and the default more is oh
I'm not going to interact because it's
because it brings stuff up and so it's
easier just to to be in my own space and
there's a lot more permission for that
to to like well it's just more normal I
mean you know I touched my head when I
could get upset but like you know just
being out in public I mean people are so
separate from each other you you know if
you're on a you know Bart you're on a
train like rarely do people interact
with each other and and and and for me
that's just really hard because I just
love interacting with people and I look
playing I mean I take the Sun I take
this on Bart I just on buses I take out
in public and I just throw it at people
because you know so that's but what I
see is that that's just increasingly
hard for people to get out of their
shell to get out of their concerns that
we're we're just so in our minds and so
locked in this concerns and worries that
it's it's hard to to reach out to
another person how are we leveraging the
exponential technologies and how often
are our leverage points towards our
nature based spiritual evolution and how
often are they distractive away from
that and actually away from harmonizing
with nature and with each other it's an
excellent excellent point do you feel
like the relationship of but how do you
feel about the relationship between free
will and determinism
well would wear like that make a bet is
you know what created all this I don't
know and we can talk about
synchronicities and like how that can
happen in the universe it's random but
your question reel in yeah so what I say
is I don't know if this is a simulation
or someone's controlling all this but
I'm [ __ ] gonna take my next breath
and I'm gonna open to the magnificence
ah and nothing's gonna stop me from
taking this breath and opening to the
magnificence as fully as I can so I
don't know if I free will
I don't know ultimately because there's
me I've had so many synchronicities I
have so many things like it's just like
this is mind boggling yeah but but okay
okay we live in a synchronistic universe
no one could have predicted when this
earth started four and half billion
years ago that this would happen mmm
right that that human beings would
evolve from that I mean not only that
but the synchronicity of how that
happened yeah yeah okay do you know
about the moon you know where the moon
came from from a collision something
okay so something smashing the earth the
moon came out of the earth okay I didn't
realize this is it
the moon is a quarter of the size of the
earth yeah okay that's huge
something hit the earth and a quarter of
it is now 250 thousand miles away
orbiting us well until that happened
earth was spinning way faster we're
spinning so fast that like seasons and
like that weather systems couldn't exist
the way they do now but because the moon
got positioned where it is and the size
of it is it actually slowed the Earth's
rotation considerably that allowed
seasons that happen that allowed this
ecosystem to form with
that's total synchronicity yeah if that
would happen and then the same thing
about the dinosaurs yeah correct right
the dinosaurs being destroyed now that
that series that Will Smith narrates the
blue ball blue strange blue ball or
something like that stuff blue something
I just saw this thing and it's like so
you know the the meteor hit and and we
went into the cold and and everything
well the reason why it was it's it was
so toxic it's because it landed in a
sulphur field so it was in Yucatan so
sulphur went up into the atmosphere
that's what poisoned everything it
wasn't just like landing anywhere but
landed in the ocean it wouldn't have
happened the difference between where it
landed and land in the ocean the earth
is spinning
that's the miles an hour out it's access
right when 24 hours it's right thousand
miles if it was like two seconds later
we would have gone in the ocean and not
where it landed so I get choked up
because it's just a synchronistic
universe that allowed all of us that
happen yes and so some argue that it may
not necessarily be just so synchronistic
but rather there are there are there is
there are other powers that are at play
in this grand experiment that's
happening and that's a very interesting
time look as well so if there are other
powers that are allowing synchronicity
that happen the same ones that you know
so whatever whatever is above this
synchronistic magnificence is happening
I don't give a [ __ ] about those things
like that's that's beyond my paygrade
right like that's happening in this
reality I certainly feel like I have
freewill and I'm gonna get very [ __ ]
thing I can to open to the beginning
magnificence as fully as I can that's
all I know so
to me it's it's yes it's not even worth
thinking about and the last question
that we like are asking our guests what
are your do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world the most
beautiful thing the most beautiful thing
is is any point anything in creation
that exists that that that boggles the
mind now of course I mean I raised
children I was there I was a midwife for
one of my children's birth okay so that
certainly was a beautiful moment to be
an adobe house a hundred-year-old adobe
house with my three kids by by candle
light as our baby came into the world it
was just my wife and I I delivered the
baby Wow okay so that was a beautiful
moment yeah to have that that yeah and
beauty is everywhere beauty is simply
everywhere every aspect of creation and
even the beauty of this trial that we're
going through the beauty of the human
spirit I mean
to save human beings who who are being
treated like [ __ ] they're just like
they're just subject to all this [ __ ]
and everything everything coming out of
the media everything that people have to
do I'm sorry I take a little longer
because this is so I just did this
African dance class and they were saying
these are the motions that the women
would do to encourage the men to do the
farming the hard work right and I think
about Carla young wrote a book it's it's
a collection of his books about nature
that so earth has a soul and what he
says is think about about the farmer and
the farmer's wife who create this him
just as their it to work the soil and to
create food to give the people that they
care about right that they have work
that's meaningful and and think about
how that feels to be a person who has
meaningful warpless can it's connected
to all things compared to someone who's
like working an office job that has this
is like it sees no value and what they
do oh yeah that that right so what I
when you're acid that beauty I think
about the human beings who work they do
this work that's not meaningful that I
mean they're given and then I mean
obviously the most vulnerable who have
just been so oppressed but the human
spirit that shines through the people
are so good I mean I talk parenting
classes in the gl3
several years I mean there's not bad
people people are just magnificent and
despite everything did that if you know
it's not surprising to me when someone
does something that's mean or even
horrific it's almost like it's
surprising how little that happens can
Hira do people who who've got nothing
been given so little and yet they're so
basically good it's so critical to help
uplift the level of basic needs being
met around the world so people can bring
their gifts most fully forth and shared
with their selves their families the
communities in the world at large it's a
main principle of our ethos in thank you
so much for this conversation I'm gonna
still throw another political thing like
Andrew Lang I just found that about him
and I'm not saying like he should be
President but the fact that he's
bringing up that GDP does not measure
everything when he says my wife takes
care of our kids and it has no value to
GDP has no value and you see all this
emphasis on money as God money is now
God and the outer is God and not the
inner and not the human qualities and
not the caring and being that that's an
essential conversation to have as we
move forward that it's not just about
how GDP goes but it's about human beings
and nature and and that's what we need
to value so yeah thank you
but brother maybe to me you are
incredible I love this conversation so
much such a pleasure thank you thank you
very enlightening
it's just nature based spiritual
evolution doing that and getting more
and more used to are are endeavoring in
that direction waking up in the morning
and when we go to bed at night instead
of rolling over grabbing the devices
instead of that go out and connect to
the Sun like stretch your body connect
to the burette via the breath there's
just so unlimited amount of practices
and to do nature based spiritual
evolution is critical I love it this is
such a great conversation thank you
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear our
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
also do check out the links in the bio
below and support Josh on his endeavor
support us support the organizations
around the world do you believe in the
spiritual leaders the artists the
entrepreneurs you can find all our links
below to our patreon or cryptocurrency
or PayPal you can design cool merch and
get paid all those links are below and
again just share more of these
conversations with your friends families
co-workers people online go on more
nature based spiritual evolutionary
journeys please go do that more everyone
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you Ori Shapiro
for producing greatly appreciate it and
we'll see you